we have not done more closely and
food technology does for us
certain technologies such as
pressurization range increases the danger of
food preservation and and simultaneously
protects us against
harmful bacteria technology powered by
microchip in the air inside
food packaging in order to
preserve the safe  natural color and textures
of books adding
antioxidants half of our food
as fresh as possible and for a
longer period and at the same time prevents it from
deteriorating, preserving its
best qualities in our homes
we can have modern
ecological refrigerators that, in addition to maintaining the
our fresh and tasty food
consumes much less energy when making it
in sumé food technology to avoid
this and preserve it
food technology in europe has bought
higher standards of control to
protect our health and keep
our food fresh and tasty
our economy  strong and
food technology for food consumption at
its best